ou est-ce qu'on est ici on est à issy
les moulineaux on est chez qui on est
chez tcl dans le showroom de tcl pour me
représenter ça ça c'est quoi et bien ça
c'est une révolution je sais que souvent
le mot révolution et beaucoup employé il
ya un côté un peu galvaudé mais là ça ne
l'est pas du tout parce que tu es si
elle a réussi quelque chose que personne
n'avait fait c'est à dire d'avoir
absolument 0 espace entre la couche de
rétroéclairage et la couche de cristaux
liquides qui va vous éviter tous les
effets de blooming mais je vais tout
détailler tout vous expliquer on est sur
un monument on est sûrs en meubles on
est sur une télé huit cas on est sur une
dalle 85 pouces ya que du 85 pouces ici
le produit c'est le x 92 pro de tcl au
10 0 et franchement ça envoie du bois
[Musique]
on est sur une dalle 85 pouces on est
sur la mini l'aide de troisième
génération signée tcl ces deux-là huit
cas on a du sens hertz la technologie
audi 0 elle est relativement énorme et
c'est très impressionnant ce qui se
passe mais pour autant à 9999 euros
c'est pas forcément un produit vous
allez avoir chez vous me prenez pas peur
partez pas en courant les innovations
arrive toujours par le très haut de
gamme pourra prévenir ceux diffusés sur
le milieu de gamme puis sur l'entrée de
gamme donc c'est le début c'est le début
cette nouvelle technologie qui est très
intéressante et ce qui est beau ici
c'est le travail d'industrialisation
d'innovation la conception qui est fait
par tcl ne prenez pas peur ça c'est un
meuble c'est un gros monument une fois
de plus on est là pour montrer
l'innovation pour notre côté si elle
sait faire et c'est pas se produire
comme ça que vous allez avoir chez vous
si vous le voulez vous pouvez il sera en
vente à partir de la fin de l'année 9999
euros c'est un beau bébé mais ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est de voir la
technologie voir ce que nous propose
teisseire a regardé je tourne les bras
je n'arrive pas à toucher les bords d'un
côté et de l'autre coucou je suis caché
derrière ce que vous avez ici c'est tout
simplement une télé modulaire ça vous
aurez trois configurations la toute
première configuration c'est que vous
l'avez ici comme ça à savoir votre
téléviseur que vous avez retrouvé posé
sur son socle avec en bas sa barre de
son qu'il ya plein de choses à raconter
je vous le dirai tout à l'heure vous
allez retrouver juste derrière planqué
ici un subwoofer qui est en blue tooth
donc vous pouvez sans la voir comme ça
ça c'est mon éclairage alors n'ayez pas
d'inquiétude là-dessus c'est mon
éclairage mais j'en ai bien juste là
ayant un deuxième qui est juste là donc
vous pouvez la voir soit comme ça s'en
vient a posé sur un meuble auquel cas
vous allez pouvoir basculer votre barre
de son est gardé votre subwoofer ou
alors carrément enlever votre barre de
son est apposée sur un mail donc à trois
configurations point même la poser sur
un mur si vous souhaitez le fait pas
forcément de même c'est un petit peu
lourd mais vous pouvez faire poser très
facilement ce qui est super intéressant
avec un subwoofer comme ça qui connecté
en bluetooth vous pouvez mettre où vous
voulez donc pas besoin de le garder
darier alors si vous voulez pour une
question d'esthétique le laisser
derrière il a laissé dans cette
configuration là vous pouvez mais si
vous voulez prendre et le déporter vous
pouvez faire très facile mais qu'est ce
qui nous intéresse ici ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la technologie c'est à
dire on est une technologie mini l'aide
ici c'est de la mini l'aide de troisième
génération alors je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant et si vous êtes
coutumier de la mine il faut savoir tcl
est le pionnier au niveau de la
midinette la sortie sa première version
de la minuad en 2018 dont fred en sont à
la troisième génération ici vous avez 96
1768 l'aide cd mini l'aide beaucoup plus
petite que de la lettre traditionnelle
là où il est normal fera 3000
micromètres ici elle fera 150 2
micromètres beaucoup plus petit
forcément c'est de la mini vous avez ici
en tout et pour tout 2016 zone avec dans
chaque zone 48 min l'aide alors on va se
faire un petit calcul 2000 ces zones x
48 je vous dis pas de bêtises 96 1768
c'est le nombre de minutes total que
vous allez avoir et ce qui est
intéressant c'est c'est 2016 zone elles
sont gérées indépendamment
ça vous paraîtra d'avoir une
optimisation avec les midinettes
optimisation au niveau de la couleur
optimisation au niveau des contrastes en
plus ici vous êtes sûre du kurel du
quantum dots ce qui vous permettra
d'avoir de meilleurs noirs des blancs
plus blanc fin bref des images beaucoup
plus belles meilleur contraste plus de
luminosité on est si un pic de
luminosité à 1800 dit que les avantages
a quasiment 10 millions on est d'accord
mais là où ce téléviseur prend nos
dimensions sa technologie aux 10 euros
normalement sur un téléviseur lcd vous
avez 12 mm c'est la distance qui sépare
la couche de rétro éclairage de la
couille de cristaux liquides 12 mm ici 0
10 0 ce qui vous permet de venir éviter
tous les effets de blooming que vous
allez pouvoir retrouver sans le
téléviseur au niveau des noirs donc le
noir et noir net ya pas de souci alors
une fois de plus cette vidéo n'est pas
un test je suis sur un prototype donc je
ne peux pas le valider comme si je vous
le disais lors d'un test mais surtout
qu'à la promesse qui est fait ici
surtout qu'à l'innovation convient de
trouver ici mais surtout ce qui est
super intéressant c'est la finesse
regardez c'est totalement fin et si vous
regardez je pose mon pouce ici eh bien
mon pouce est plus large plus épais que
le téléviseur parce que vous avez une
finesse de dingue c'est justement là
qu'est l'innovation avec l'audi 0 ce qui
nous permet de gagner vraiment en terme
de finesse et regardez je vous montre un
autre téléviseur minitel de chez tcl les
bords c'est pas la même chose et là je
pose mon doigt ça sera notre référentiel
ça reste quand même petit ça reste quand
même fin mais pour autant je vois
légèrement les bords sur le côté et par
rapport à l'eau 10 euros c'est
complètement dingue et c'est ça qui est
vraiment génial parce que là aujourd'hui
vous le voyez sur un téléviseur de 85
pouces qui est quand même un meuble un
faut le dire il est quand même très très
très énorme mais imaginez lorsque ça
arrivera chez vous que vous aurez un
téléviseur 55 pouces 65 pouces 75 et que
ça j'ai encore en fonction et bien de la
taille de votre appartement de ce que
vous allez pouvoir dire logeait
appartement ou maison et bien vous
pourrez la fixer au mur avec une finesse
qui sera vraiment vraiment tout tout
tout petit et c'est ça qui est vraiment
hyper intéressant c'est de voir comment
est ce qu'on arrive comment est-ce que
des ingénieurs des concepteurs de
produits arrivent à résoudre des
problèmes physiques en venant optimisé
justement la qualité d'affichage en ont
supprimé la problématique de blooming et
pour tous ceux qui se le demandent aux
10 euros c'est la traduction de
profondeur optique nul zéro c'est
compris 12 mm collet c'est cool le mini
l'aide le plus chambre avec ça et c'est
super intéressant tient plus et que vous
avez une dalle 8k
7680 par 4320 c'est grand c'est très
grand c'est quatre fois plus grand que
du 4k et hd et 16 fois plus grand que du
full hd alors vous me direz si moi par
exemple je me regarde du contenu sur
youtube qui affichait en full hd qui a
même pas en 4k est ce que ça va
fonctionner oui oui parce que forcément
derrière vous invite technologie qui
s'appelle de l'umps kyling c'est à dire
que ils vont venir créer des pixels pour
que vous ayez quelque chose de bonne
qualité en plus ici vous êtes h dernis
plus dolby vision et tout ce qui va bien
derrière comme si sur un proto est en
tout cas toujours un petit peu compliqué
à venir à vérifier si ces les angles de
vision mais bon on regarde et on fait le
tour comme ça on est ensemble on teste
ça directement ensemble on voit toujours
mon reflet ici demander terrasse mais
sinon dans l'ensemble ça semble quand
même fait le taf on est sur un proto
donc il faut vraiment vraiment envie de
le préciser ici et toute la partie
antireflet qui aussi compliqué d'autant
plus que dans un show room avec tous les
éclairages qu'on a un peu de tous les
côtés ben c'est pas forcément il paraît
pas évident il ya nautique est super
intéressant c'est qu'ici je suis sûre du
sang efs ils appellent ça le sens hertz
motion clarity pour tous ceux qui ne
sont pas coutumiers du terme hertz hertz
est le nombre d'image que vous allez
avoir par seconde par défaut une télé un
peu standard ça va être du 60 m c'est à
dire 60 images par seconde donc plus
vous mettez d'image dans un intervalle
de temps donc plus vous mettez d'image
dans une seconde et plus vous allez
avoir de la fluidité et ça ne s'arrête
pas là parce que si vous êtes un gamer
est aussi un très beau bénéfices avec
trois ports hdmi de points en ce qui
vous permettra sur ces trois ports et
bien dès lors vous avez une console
compatible de faire de la 4k à 120
images par seconde donc en terme
d'expérience de guémy c'est vachement
bien et le quatrième point vous pourrez
jouer en 4k 60 images par seconde bon
déjà trois ports 120 fps ça va ya de
quoi faire et quand des jeux arriveront
en 8k vous pourrez faire ici delà du cas
à 60 fps là je vous parle d'image vous
parle d'innovation au niveau de la
conception je vous parle de nouveautés
de conception et d'industrialisation
mais tu dois je vous ai pas encore parlé
c'est l'audio parce que oui avoir des
images c'est bien mais si derrière vous
n'avez pas une expérience audio qui à la
hauteur et mais ça peut faire un petit
peu râler mais justement ici une fois de
plus ils ont mis la barre très très
haute avec un partenariat avec onkyo
vous avez en tout 25 hauts parleurs 25
ans parlant répartie alors je vous
explique dans votre barre de son vous
avez 24 par leur gré des haut parleurs
qui vont projeter le son vers l'avant
bien évidemment d'être enfin nous
entende et ça me paraît normal mais vous
en avez d'autres vont projeter le saut
vers le haut ce qui va venir apporter en
terme d'immersion pour avoir un son qui
vous entourent plus le seul bouffeurs
qui est derrière vous vous rappelez vous
en ai parlé de ce fameux subwoofer qui
est en blue tooth qu'on va pouvoir venir
des places et dolby et klaus dts imac
saônates toujours dur à dire imac
standing et en termes de connectique
vous avez ce qu'il faut je lui ai dit
vous avez 3 j'ai des amis les trois
délits que vous voyez là c'est de la jda
mis deux points sans vous avez une
entrée ethernet vous avez un câble
d'antenne vous avez une sortie optique
vous avez un autre hdmi en irc vous avez
de l'usb vous avez même une sortie
casque et qui dit elle est dite et les
commandes ici c'était celle vous avez
deux télécommandes pour ce téléviseur de
pour le prêt d'une c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal alors on va commencer par
la grande c'est très standard ce qu'on
va me retrouver ici au niveau des
boutons donc il n'y a rien qui va
devenir vous surprendre sans la grande
télécommande d'un gros bouton netflix en
bas mais sinon bon rien dit à des gosses
qui se sont prononcés que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya pas de
rétroéclairage a priori les finitions ne
sont pas définitives a donc comme on est
sur un proto sous réserve de voir les
choses évoluer très très prochainement
je l'espère parce que en l'état c'est
pas forcément les télécommandes qui font
le plus premium sur un téléviseur a
quasiment dix mille euros la petite
télécommande est plutôt sympa pouvoir
des accès rapides pour le multimédia
vous voyez que votre bouton google
assistant en hausse et à de nouvelles
tilly mais on va regarder ça dans
quelques instants puis vous avez le
choix un buteur il ya tout le monde un
netflix prennent vidéo go hard médias
youtube tcl channel youtube c'est bien
quand vous voulez venir me voir vous
appuyez dessus et pas j'arrive dans
votre salon bon et après je vous
passerai rapidement mais vous avez toute
l'expérience google tv ne sais pas si
vous connaissez
tv ce sera le meilleur agrégateur que
vous avez aujourd'hui pour accéder
directement à votre contenu que vous
cherchez du contenu va regarder sur tik
tok typiquement ici que ce soient des
films que ce soit sur netflix que ce
soit sur my canal que ce soit sur
n'importe quoi et que si vous êtes dans
l'écosystème google et bien vous allez
pouvoir avoir des ponts direct entre
votre compte google votre google tv bref
c'est vachement bien et ça je vous
invite à venir le découvrir pour en
termes de solutions ici logiciel vous
avez ce qu'il faut aussi et en plus sur
le dessus qui est planté juste ici et
bien vous avez une webcam alors pas pour
venir vous regarder lorsque vous
regardez vos films comme vous avez dû
google tv vous avez dû google duo et
vous allez pouvoir venir échanger avec
votre famille si vous avez la famille
qui est loin si vous avez des amis qui
sont bruns vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de vous voir google duo la
magic caméra qui est là et ça c'est très
pratique alors cette magie caméra elle
sort lorsque vous allumez votre
télévision sinon le rentre-dedans donc
pour les plus frileux il ya personne qui
l'a vient vous regardez chez vous dans
votre intérieur en termes de sécurité
c'est bien qu'on est sur un téléviseur
qui arrive à la fin de l'année c'est un
téléviseur de nice et de l'innovation
que c'est parce que vous en pensez à ce
que ça vous botte une techno comme ça
est ce que vous êtes sensible à de la
mine il est 3eme génération signée tcl
est ce que la technologie audi 0 vous
paraît pertinente et alors on se
projette pas tout dit à se dire je met
quasiment dix mille euros sur une télé
comme ça mais peut-être que plus tard
lorsque la technologie a évolué que les
prix vont mécaniquement baisser est ce
que ça pourrait vous tenter mark et moi
bien évidemment tout ça en bas aux
commentaires et nous on va continuer je
me retourne et se mettre un petit film
ben oui forcément je suis là j'en
profite dans le showroom de tesselles on
est plutôt pas mal je vous dis à bientôt
et moi je me regarde je pars les
aristochats j'aime beaucoup les
aristochats et c'est magnifique ciao
[Musique]